let's go into our checklist for today
again you can check all these checklists
that this week in startups.com checklist
and i'm doing this as much for you as
for me you can take this checklist and
you can edit it you can write a blog
post about it you can remix it if you
want to make a pdf out of it for us all
i ask is that you put that link in take
it from this week in startups by jcal
and his team this week in startups.com
checklist if you want to make a pdf just
non-commercial please but if you want to
remix this or rethink it or change it or
you know say what you think is wrong or
better about it let's make it a living
doc put your comments in this weekend
startups.com checklist
okay item number one for today because
we're gonna talk about operational
uh excellence optimizing your operations
is today's theme so number one
which is number 61 in our overall
checklist so 61 on our checklist number
one for today do you have a low burn
culture
i want you to ask yourself that question
because as a founder you set the tone
for everything in your company
especially how you spend money and you
typically have
um more to do
than other companies because you're
trying to create something new in the
world and you have less resources that
means you have to have a low burn
culture
so you don't want to have excessive
spending you want to spend intelligently
this means
when you hire somebody and they say hey
listen google and facebook are offering
me x
plus y and z
your response is we can offer you 50 of
x and there's no way we can offer you y
and z but we will offer you a b and c
the ability to direct what you're doing
here
be part of something exciting not soul
crushing like optimizing an ad network
at facebook
or working for our dystopian future in
the metaverse
and uh c you're gonna get stock options
which will in all likelihood be worth
zero but could be worth a lot more than
zero if we all figure this out and we're
in it together so essentially what
you're saying is no we we're not gonna
compete with that and and you don't want
anybody who wants you to compete with
that if they say hey i'm getting
you know 18 weeks off and i'm getting
rsu's and i'm getting uh you know my car
paid for whatever nonsense it is i'm
getting severance you say yeah we can't
compete with that sorry no
and then once you've set that
expectation
then you're going to want to really
negotiate things hard so every time you
have a vendor you want to negotiate if
you've got a lawyer you can say hey can
you do our legal work at this flat rate
can you
do our fundraising at a max of twenty
thousand dollars you'd be surprised how
many uh lawyers will actually agree to
cap their fees or will negotiate their
fees or accountants
to keep you in business and support you
in the early days so don't be afraid to
ask for a discount or to ask for a cap
on services
you don't need to get fancy office space
obviously we know in pandemic you can
build just as easily
we would do our meetings at
you know uh
a burger joint or
we would you know brian alvey and i and
peter rojas and ryan block and tron gold
when we got together to do weblogs inc
we were in cafes you know doing stuff
for free you don't need to waste your
money on swag or things that you see big
companies doing everything goes into the
product everything goes into sales and
growth and you really try to scale your
startup intelligently
and on episode 934 in our scaling uh
your startup series
which is about something different than
the checklist that was about growth we
did talk about low burn culture and you
can double click on that if you want to
now related to this item 62 on our
checklist of 100 items
can you calculate your burn rate and
runway so first you need to know your
revenue in some cases it's going to be
zero so let's say in your one you you're
gonna have no revenue just gonna be
building product building team and
getting some beta customers and unpaid
trials which i never really think you
should do i think you should always do
pay trials but let's just say it's an ad
based business and you decided for year
one you'll spend six months building it
six months having free users and in year
two you'll address paid
well if you spend a hundred thousand a
month your burn is a hundred thousand
now if you were to
in month thirteen
have 10 000 in advertising revenue and
it grew 50 a month and you got to 15k
and then you got to 25 et cetera you
would and your spend stayed the same
you're going to have 100 minus 10k 90k
burn the next month let's say you bring
in 15k in revenue 100k steady state burn
that's all your salaries legal expenses
etc minus the 15k 85 in burn okay next
month you did let's say 25. now you're
at 75 okay in burn
whatever you spend minus what you made
there's whatever that net is that is
your burn rate sometimes i'll have
people calculate their burn rate as
their entire spend
they just don't understand this
calculation it's what's going out of the
business every month it's basically a
way of saying your loss and burning cash
means you're losing money
another way of framing losing money is
investing in your business which is what
we're doing here in silicon valley we're
saying instead of you bootstrapping the
business and spending what you make
we'll accelerate your growth we'll trust
you to spend some money
intelligently and we'll take the risk
that hey maybe the revenue never shows
up and this thing goes out of business
or gets sold in a fire sale but you do
need to know how to calculate it once
you have your burn rate what you can do
is you can look at how much did you
lose in the last three months and you
could average it so in the example i
gave
you know for the 13th 14th 15th month
you know in your second year with the
advertising we had 10km revenue 15k in
revenue and 25km revenue if you add
those three numbers together 25 plus 15
is 40 and then 10 is 50. you got 50k and
you spent 300 so in the first quarter
you spent 300 000 you made 50 that means
you burned 250 if you divide 250 by
three you're basically burning 83 000 a
month so your average burn was 83. if
you don't think you're gonna grow
revenue in the next nine months you
could say hey
83 times 12 and you get an idea of what
you're going to spend for the year in
that case it would be roughly
uh a million dollars is what you're
going to burn for the year why is it
important to know this well then you can
take your burn rate
you can look at your cash in the bank
and you can do it very simple i'm going
to divide
uh our 830 000 in the bank by 83
thousand dollars in burn a month okay
i've got 10 months of runway okay if you
had 1.7 million in the bank okay now you
got 20 months of runway very easy
calculation super easy to do you should
know this as the founder and you should
be looking at not just your accounting
but also the cash balance because
sometimes you'll have one-time expenses
you won't take that into account you
have to pay off a 50k legal bill
you know whatever you know some big you
bought 10 laptops
you understand this is why people like
to spread out their spend over time and
they like to be very cautious about this
so understand your burn and what your
real goal is i think
is to have 18 to 24 months of runway in
the bank at all times i think that that
is
the best way to run a company
in the early stages why
sounds too conservative because it means
you have at least a year to be heads
down and not worry about money
you can go 12 months iterate two or
three times figure it out you'll be able
to sleep at night maybe not chew your
teeth and grind them down to nubs
and then you know
you'll be watching this and maybe you
say you know what we got enough traction
here i'm going to start raising in month
13 i'll need six months to raise the
next round or you can say god nothing's
working i need to meet with my board in
month 789 and get some idea of a pivot
here or what i should do
and really it's like in the case of a
pilot understanding your altitude and
your speed and just knowing hey my
descent is x
and my speed is y my altitude is z
i can get to a runway oh i'm low i just
took off and i lost both engines like
sully
okay i'm not making it to t to borrow
i'm not making it to jfk that's not
happening i'm going in the hudson
remember that live call you can insert
that here we're going to be in the
hudson
it was incredible moment what a hero uh
you know sometimes you just you need to
ditch and the equivalent in a startup is
you shut the company down and you're
going to return the money if you have
money left or you're just going to make
sure everybody gets a soft landing and
gets off the plane and the plane's going
to sink and be totaled that's not what
you're trying to do in that situation
you're just trying to get everybody off
the plane
safely uh it's not life and death but it
is nice to close things up cleanly so
that you can go start another company
before i start the ad read just go to
linkedin.com checklist and you will get
a hundred dollar credit towards your
first ad campaign on linkedin okay let's
get to the ad read here every startup
founder and marketer has been in this
situation you know it well you're
planning to launch your new campaign you
know your audience the team is happy
everything's going according to plan you
love your creative but you got that one
thought in the back of your head don't
you how can i be sure that my
acquisition campaign will drive high
impact leads for my sales team
you need those high quality leads we all
know that and with linkedin ads you
don't need to guess because when you
advertise on linkedin your message
reaches the people who are ready to
engage you they're in the business
mindset you know that linkedin equals
business business equals linkedin the
end over 30 million companies are active
on linkedin today and over 71 percent of
professionals use linkedin to make
business decisions so startup marketers
don't wait to start achieving your brand
and lead gen goals no linkedin is
offering our listeners exclusively a 100
ad credit to get started today get the
hundy and
get your first linkedin campaign up and
running at linkedin.com checklist
linkedin.com checklist terms and
conditions apply because they're giving
you a hundy